your own facts right but it was all
about being popular
right and even politicians picked up
those symptoms politicians tweet now
they want to be popular
we had a referendum about brexit because
they were passing the book they didn't
want to make a mistake so
and the other thing is this ridiculous
thing of them oh
let's ask the average person what they
think let's stop asking the average
person
do you know how [ __ ] stupid the
average person is
we still sell bottles of bleach with big
labels on
that say do not drink all right
let's take those labels off right for
two years
and then have a referendum
[Applause]
you've worked with really funny people
yeah yeah who do you think is funny like
who do you love good question
uh right now or who i worked with
the guy who worked with her that was the
finances chris farrell oh yeah
by a million miles he was like all the
time funny yeah just everyone was
laughing
like and he could he's one of those guys
get anyone like a dumb person or a smart
person or a
an old person or a young a little kid or
anybody he could get people that didn't
like him to laugh
so it's really nice what are you guys
all looking for oh look there's a
picture of youtube
did i ever tell you that time uh one of
my friends
was was on this i can't say he was on a
date
you know that [ __ ] when you were like
high school and you're basically
drinking outside and you just start
talking to something broad
and you try to hook up with her all
right so it's getting to dusk and there
was this moment
okay right around dusk
where the sun's going down and the moon
was uh
sounds like a [ __ ] song doesn't it um
the sun was going down and the moon
be like sun's going down in the west and
the moon was kind of like i don't know i
guess at like two o'clock or whatever
and this girl was going and someone said
oh wow the sun and the moon are out at
the same time wow you know
and this girl was like wait a minute
how can the [ __ ] sunday and the movie
yeah i had a sense if i can tack it
and at first they thought that she
didn't believe that you could see the
moon until the sun
completely went down which i guess would
be understandable
but they quickly realized that she
thought that the sun
and the moon were the same thing
and that evidently
at night i guess god or
jesus or buddha would
i don't know necessarily blow this i
guess she thought the sun was on a
dimmer
and they would just so sort of gradually
bring it down
and uh i don't know i don't [ __ ] know
and that's just one of those moments
where you're always a kid you just have
that first
moment of is this thing too dumb
to try and [ __ ] you know i always had
that i could never [ __ ] somebody well i
really thought was stupid
it just it just felt like uh it was a
form of rape
you know what i mean if you're just so
like i don't even say i'm a smart guy
but you know when someone's just like
borderline like wow
high school really and college college
wow okay all right
now we're in west palm beach or palm
beach
where's palm beach and uh you said
pressure
what'd you say you're not sure
thank you for saying that out loud i
really
feel like that got us somewhere
who the [ __ ] answers the question
without knowing
in a room of 600 people you could just
be
quiet right like that's what most people
would do
right hey is it raining outside
it was you oh that's what's up
thank you what is the difference sir you
have no idea you're a big [ __ ] latino
man
holy [ __ ] dude did they just hop on you
as the boat from cuba
[Applause]
everybody just know how hot this this
plants francine is very hot yeah
the little nubian princess well she is
pregnant and she's almost smart
well oh she's slow down not too smart
sorry of course you guys elsa
yep for law school law school now you're
going to go
to law school it's a law school yeah
oh my gosh he's dumb this is fantastic
she's not even close to smart she says
she's smart she actually said what did
you say about the news and how
how uh she she comes in to do the news
for us but
she usually stays up all night writing
the news because it's really hard to put
stories together
what stories together that are that
already exist
but to make it into five uh sentences
it's real hard oh you prince you
practice them you you put them you make
them more you want to hear her news
patrice you're in for a treat ladies and
gentlemen without further ado
it's francine with the news oh god bless
the world
we got the teletype or any of that stuff
all right here we go
a cambodian couple attacked their 12
year old daughter
in her sleep by biting off her
thumbnails and nipping at her
nose so they can suck her blood silly
goops
sucking blood is for freaks goops
gooks oh
is that how you're going to deliver your
um summation of a trial maybe you're
closing arguments
in that space
[Music]
it was a crime as you can see my client
is
innocent are you drunk
because all you did was ride a cooler
and you're sweating i am well it's no
it's hot is it
it's hotter than a well he's got like 12
layers on it yeah i thought it was going
to be really
cold from canada this should be like
this should be springtime no i know i'm
from canada but you know i'm still a
human being
it's not like it revolved
[Laughter]
yeah yeah it gets colder than uh
it gets colder than that oh here it goes
get your finger on the panic button no
it gets colder than a vampire's demeanor
wow surprisingly cerebral
man you know living the great light
living the dream every day
every day did you enjoy that bit we did
with driving around
it was really hysterical yeah i got a
late uh i got a late they
they they put me in late i don't think
i'd have to where did you go did you
take a spin around the station i
couldn't find you you drove way too far
down the road
i i got a i got a heavy foot there's a
real stream of consciousness thing
happening here in norway yeah it's
called conversation
the only time i had you know one time i
was with this woman and we're fooling
around
and she asked me uh she was like uh have
you heard anybody shove anything up your
ass your first rather
and i said uh no
that's a question you can answer right
away if it's
no i don't think so no no i know i have
no
and then she asked me well uh uh do you
want something up your ass have you ever
wanted that have you ever felt like you
wanted to
i thought you know no i mean i've never
really felt like uh
anything was really missing from up
there you know i think
i'm all set in that i never really saw
anything in the world that made me go
you know that really should be in my ass
why isn't that
come on put that in my ass what are you
doing come on
so you know that's
then she asked me um uh would you let me
put something in your ass and now we're
moving up the thing you know it's have
you know or do what you want no would
you let
that's a different thing you know so i
said well what do you what like what
and she said well what would you let me
put in your ass and
i never had to make this list before i
don't know
definite nose you know disneyland i
don't want that up there you know
and not because it's too big just
because it's not i hate the
whole you know mickey mouse he's not
funny you know he was never funny i was
like kiddies
this isn't like bugs bunny's funny and i
say hey
you know he's a funny guy and he had
jokes and he was funny but mickey mouse
was just always you know
too much water or something like that
you know